nasa made history overnight with the
launch of a mission that sounds like
science fiction but aims to protect our
planet from a very real threat a
devastating aeris
asteroid strike for the first time a
nasa spacecraft will try to knock an
asteroid off course mark strassman shows
us why this planetary defense mission is
so critical
look out in the 1998 sci-fi thriller
armageddon an asteroid the size of texas
is on a collision course with planet
earth united states government just has
to save the world and actor bruce willis
jumps in to save us all you're going to
remote detonate the bomb
[Applause]
[Music]
so in hollywood they blow it up right
you just you don't want to blow it up
because that doesn't change
the direction of all the material it's
still coming at you it's just buckshot
instead of a rifle bullet lindley
johnson ought to know well i'm the real
bruce willis you are
he is
nasa's real-life planetary defense
officer trying to find asteroids in our
solar system before they find us
more than 27 000 near-earth asteroids
seen here in blue have been identified
so far about 10 000 of them look large
enough to cause damage if they were ever
to strike earth smaller size asteroids
even as small as
a few hundred feet in size if they were
to impact particularly in a populated
area
it would be a natural disaster on the
order of
anything that we've ever dealt with
in 2013 a meteor just 60 feet across
exploded over russia injuring more than
sixteen hundred people as it now stands
how vulnerable is the earth to one of
these objects
to a large object there was you know
currently nothing
to stop it
liftoff
but nasa just launched earth's first
planetary defense mission the double
asteroid redirection test or dart dart
is a spacecraft that's purposely going
to crash into an asteroid planetary
scientist nancy chabot is the dart
coordination lead near baltimore the
johns hopkins university applied physics
laboratory built the spacecraft so this
is dynamos chabot showed us dart's test
target a harmless double asteroid nearly
7 million miles away
didamos is about 2500 feet across next
fall dart will target dimorphos its
smaller moon an asteroid roughly the
size of the washington monument the dart
spacecraft is going to come in at 15 000
miles per hour and hit it pretty much
head on here an impact that would slow
this asteroid's orbit by about one
percent but the tactic could make a
hypothetical earth-bound asteroid miss
small nudge changes his position over
time so the earth and the asteroid
wouldn't be on a future collision course
bump it ever so slightly and knock it
off course remove the threat
correct but luckily there are no known
hazards in the next hundred or so years
but we actually haven't found all of the
asteroids yet which is why it makes
sense to be ready in case you needed to
in fact scientists believe they found
fewer than half of all near-earth
asteroids big enough to cause
devastation
of course hollywood could spot the next
threat from the sky
any time the two halves are going to
miss us by 400 miles for cbs mornings
mark strassman laurel maryland
and if anyone needs a grade school
reminder an asteroid killed the
dinosaurs and it's believed
and it's believed that an asteroid of
that size hits once every 15 million
years i don't know where we are in that
timeline but i want to win that reality
tv show okay so you're just pushing this
on everybody's table one more thing to
worry about i'm not no don't worry about
it just root for those guys the
planetary defense officer is my hero for
2021 i think we're safe
for now for now tony your kid has
right it has happened but but we've been
around for less than a million years
folks oh yes and i want to keep it that
way
that's what the dinosaurs said too
trying to have for the long term
michelle